Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
August fucking 27th August 27th what's going on?
How are you?
I'm you as you know,
I don't have a lot of guests on a,
on my podcast.
Every once in a while I'll have someone that interests me.
A middle leather chair.
I'm not like constantly farting here.
I'm just adjusting my weight.
I have one of my oldest friends in this business.
I've known this man since 1,995 when we were a couple of,
nobody's going around fucking New York trying to get spots.
He has his name.
Oh,
I just introduce you.
Unbelievable comedian.
Mr Tom Papa.
Everybody.
Nice to be here.
Bill 95.
That's amazing.
So I was only doing standup for two years when we miss that.
Right.
You were already really good.
93 I wasn't good.
I was loud.
I was loud and fast.
Well,
I remember,
uh,
Geraldo rest,
his soul used to tell me that the way you used to stand on stage,
you were in some sort of like warrior one or warrior too.
It was sort of weird.
Lean,
I called it the lunge was at lunch.
I would like lean.
Yeah.
I would kinda like bend my one leg kind of lunch that way and talk to that part
of the audience.
Then I had lunch the other way.
Talk to him about it.
Got Laughs.
So yeah,
I really thought they'd probably like,
he's a character.
He's thinking a character.
We can build a sitcom around this guy.
Look,
he's a young guy.
Like back then that was the whole thing.
Long bushy curly hair.
Ah,
um,
uh,
probably about 25 pounds heavier than I am now.
Oh,
you were heavier?
Yup.
And uh,
oh,
you were partying back then.
Who was like my crazy,
uh,
my wife calls it when she saw a tape of it.
She didn't know me back then.
She saw me probably 10 years after that.
And when she saw,
I don't know if you have like a good tape of you when you first started,
but there's like,
it's,
they're all also classic and uh,
she saw it and said it looked like my crazy brother showed up and came to town
and start doing comedy.
You're Roger Clinton showed up,
right?
Exactly.
I did kind of look Roger Clinton,
this had that kind of a,
almost a mullet,
but not really.
I got one in [inaudible],
I forget where the hell I was.
I was doing some local Boston show.
I mean it was taped,
someone's got to have the tape somewhere.
And I was wearing basically the clothes that I wore to the dental office that
day.
I was still working there.
I was definitely wearing the pants.
Right.
So I had like powder from the rubber gloves and God knows how much germs on me
cause I like the only way to make the Gig was I had to work and then just jump
in my car and go.
So I brought a chair,
a chair,
I brought a shirt.
So I had,
uh,
I had on navy blue Docker's.
Oh.
And then I had a shirt,
it was navy blue stripe and like,
like pea soup,
green horizontal stripes.
I had a big red afro up him and a shirt tucked in.
Now grunge had already hit at that point.
Nice.
So I started [inaudible] 92 so it was already like Roger's already going.
So it was like if be tucked in your shirt,
you were part of the 80s.
Ugh.
So the shot I believe was on talked might not have been now that I think about
it,
but I was,
I just remember I was pointing at the crowd every like,
like Annunciation.
I was doing this thing.
You remember when Trump did that thing,
you're fired that little snake thing,
even with his hand and they made fun of it so much he stopped doing it.
Right.
Which is kind of funny to think about now.
It's interesting though,
you with the pointing as you're telling the jokes.
I mean,
even the lunging,
yes.
Uh,
because the two guys that I want it to be kind of bad ass,
like I didn't want to be like them,
but I can look back and think like Bill Hicks and Denis leary would get in the
audience's face and they would kind of like jab at them Kinda that way.
Oh,
okay.
Were you watching those guys at that time?
I didn't even know who bill Hicks was until after he died.
Oh really?
Well,
I mean,
because Bill Hicks was not getting on mainstream stuff.
He had done a couple of letterman's,
but back then,
you know,
if he didn't know to look for them,
if you missed his letter and spot,
he just missed it.
I found him by mistake on Caroline's comedy hour.
Oh,
okay.
To Caroline's comedy hour when Caroline's was down in another location,
I think by the seaport or something for a time.
Then I saw him and he would get like right in their face.
He would at the edge of the stage,
you bend all the way down with a cigarette in someone's face and yell about
Britney Spears or whatever.
No,
he was gone before Britney spears.
I felt it that time.
Like you have no materials so you just,
you know you're funny but you have no real skill.
You got some stuff,
but then it's just pure energy.
It's just what I think that that's because I was totally like introverted,
but so that,
that was me just sort of,
I think it was just,
that was me.
I was miming throwing shit against the wall.
I think every job that I was doing,
but then as we came up through the ranks,
what amazed me about you was the way that you could like always work.
Totally clean and like you,
I mean,
yeah,
we came up,
you know,
stu would be given us the late spots.
That's how it is.
You got to earn,
you got to earn the earlier ones.
Yeah.
And Iram you'd go on after Godfrey crushing,
you know all of these guys.
You go on after my filth and you'd go out there and just totally sport coat on,
sweet and clean.
Well and just bobbed and you just killed.
I did go through some phases when,
especially when it got to the seller where I was,
you know,
going up after a towel where F for a good month I thought I've gotta be dirtier.
I've got to,
yeah,
I've got to do something.
So I started coming up with filthier stuff and I'm telling you,
just the audience knew.
They don't know me at all.
That is not this guy.
They knew I was not the guy saying these words like it wasn't,
it did not fit.
And you know what's funny is,
is what you're saying right now is all you had to say after Dave.
Yeah.
Like I'd like to continue in that dark world,
but look at me folks.
I'm not,
that guy
didn't have the courage or the wherewithal to do that.
So my only cure for it was don't watch anybody before I go on.
Just to completely stay alone and wait for them to come and get me like last
minute.
Like,
Hey,
they're calling your name and then go down.
Isn't that amazing though?
But I think people that are successful will find ways,
you know,
in situations like that they actually come up,
they'll come up with their own sort of exercise yeah.
To be la.
Right.
Well if I just don't see it,
then I don't have to like deal with it.
Yeah.
And um,
some way to preserve whatever you got to kind of do.
I did some last week when I was on Conan.
Right?
Uh Huh.
I did something that I learned at the comedy cellar.
It was a comedy cellar is small as it is.
Yeah.
It always seems so gigantic to me because it was like this place you wanted to
get into st would be watching your sets.
The fucking wait staff would report back to management and Shit and you just
never felt like you know it,
it takes a good eight years before you feel like you're in.
He did.
Totally.
So I remember Patrice had done something on stage.
I don't know what happened.
He had done something,
so they called a meeting.
It was,
this is fucking hilarious.
They call this meeting at the comedy cellar.
Okay.
And the three people showed up.
I don't all the comics.
It was me and Bobby.
I was living with Bobby Kelly,
Bobby's idea.
We got to go to the meeting,
she's going to take away I spots and I'm like,
I yelled again.
And we both went down there,
frick and frack to Boston guys.
We'd go down there.
It was us two and David Tell,
oh my God,
Patrice,
who the whole fucking meeting was about,
didn't even show up of course.
And everybody else was kind of in and it's like,
I got to get a fucking going down there.
But anyway,
we went in there and I remember waiting for a sec and Manny to get their rest,
his soul.
And I just was,
I was apps,
it was the middle of the day and I could not believe how small the club was.
Right.
And I was just like,
oh my God.
I mean I could literally,
yeah.
Move all the chairs out of here in 11 minutes by myself.
Yeah.
With sometimes I'll go down to,
to go to use the restroom even now.
And you go down there and it's just empty.
And everything's pushed aside so they can mop.
And it really is like a closet and it's because when,
I don't know what it is about that room.
Yeah.
When it gets full,
it's matching.
Yes.
And it just,
it comes this other,
this energy thing that you're just like,
and then when it's,
everybody's gone.
Yeah.
And they're like going like,
this is this place.
It's like,
you know,
so anyway,
so I went,
I had to go to Conan and I just so happened I was ready for once before the,
you know,
right.
It's the guy got there to pick you up.
Ah.
So I got there like 15 minutes early.
There was nobody there,
so I was like,
you know,
how would you just walk out there?
Why don't I just walk out and take a look at it?
Yeah.
Just so I can really have in my head how big it is.
Oh,
nice.
You know,
it was still pretty big and that's
what I mean.
But it wasn't like it's your space.
I want it to be more grounded.
Right.
So I went up,
I looked at the drum kit and stuff,
sat down,
played for like two seconds and then like walked around and talked to a couple
of people.
A few people said hello.
And then it just kind of felt like,
and I was just looking at smart.
Yeah.
That's so smart.
So cause even when you leave,
you've done the show a bunch,
but when you could walk back out it feels new again.
It's not your home.
Yes.
So I did the new again thing before the cameras were on.
Nice.
And then,
so then when I went out there,
I felt like I was,
you know,
the most present.
I didn't have that same outer body experience where afterwards I had,
would always look at Andy and be like,
was that good?
Like,
like basically what happened.
I totally,
because the whole time you're doing it,
you're thinking like nowadays too,
it's like,
did I just end my fucking career right there?
What did I say?
You know,
is this group going to come at me or fad people going to say this?
Like,
you know,
all of that shit.
So anyway,
speaking of careers,
yes you are on this podcast.
Not Cause you liked me.
Well not because she wanted to come over here and smoke a cigar afterwards with
some finding out you don't have time.
Oh I wish Tom Papa.
Um,
not only an incredible comedian.
You also bake your own bread.
Yes I do.
Which you've been doing for years and then you,
you were actually nice enough to offer to teach me and I've just never found
time to get over there.
And I brought you bread.
Oh you like a year ago.
You remember I brought it.
Oh like two times.
I vaguely remember cause it's gone that quick and it brings it over in a little
basket with this old lady.
Little towel over the top of it.
And you're like,
ah,
like you don't even need butter.
You made us say,
what did you make us?
I always get a sour sour dough.
Ah,
good stuff.
I got good for me.
And Nia basically ate the whole loaf talking about what we were going to eat it
with that night.
And we were just not the old and we were like,
we got to finish this.
So now all of a sudden,
yeah.
Um,
your,
your professional and your hobby life have now blurred here and you have a new
cooking show coming out today,
I guess,
right?
Monday a week.
A week from Labor Day.
Labor Day.
So a week from today,
what's the exact date?
Uh,
September 3rd,
third day.
10 o'clock at night.
10 o'clock east called baked.
It's called baked.
And No,
you're not putting any weed in the bread,
man.
Hey Man.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
it's not really a cooking show as much as a food show.
Like I'm not going to,
well I guess I,
I guess I am cooking basically what I did.
Well,
it's not going to be eight episodes of watching you cook bread.
No.
Okay.
Exactly.
That's,
uh,
that's kind of what I thought it was going to be.
And they're like,
this is going to be over in an episode.
So you have a hundred different kinds of loaves of bread you can make,
so we can get there to syndication.
So what I was doing,
I started baking it.
I started getting really good at it and when I would travel around on the road
doing stand during the day,
I would visit bakeries.
I would go check them out and I was just trying to learn like see what flower
they were using,
talk to them,
that kind of thing.
Yeah,
you got into it.
I got into it and they caught wind of it and thought it would be a cool show
because I'm already doing it.
I'm going to these places and then you know I'm going to learn.
I'm super curious about it and they didn't have any show that just dealt with
baked goods.
Can you back up for a second?
How did they catch wind of it?
I have that Alexis in your fucking house or something.
How do they catch wind and you're a comic killing a day and you're going to
bakeries,
because I started talking about it on social media.
I talked about an on Rogan's podcast.
I talked about it on Conan and in the New York Times did an article on people
with sourdough starters.
You know,
the sourdough starter is the mother,
the mother.
I hate that.
I saw,
it's the thing,
there's,
there's like a thing in France,
the,
some of them have,
they're like a,
they're like a couple hundred years old.
Like you just keep feeding it some sort of bacteria or no,
you just keep feeding it flour and in water and it eats it.
And what that season alive.
Yeah.
It's the act of yeast in there.
And so you've got to feed it flour and water and it eats it.
And so it's like they've had a goldfish that they'd been feeding for like the
last since like the early 18 hundreds.
Yeah.
And it's a little vague that when people say it's a hundred years old,
I mean,
cause you like nobody ever is spelt it,
it has its origin.
Like it has it,
you will have,
it will connect to however long you've been feeding it,
but you're dumping a lot of it and then new flower and water's going in.
But just a cool story.
Yeah.
You know,
and uh,
now I feel like a novice,
like people do care about it.
People do like hang on to them,
pass them down to other people in their family.
And it is a thing like you,
my,
I have two of them and they're in my refrigerator and I've been on the road now
for a week.
I just got home today and I know when I leave you I'm going to go home and feed
them cause it's been a week.
If you don't feed it,
it slowly starts to become less active.
It has no food to eat and then it starts creating its own alcohol and that's it.
When you come back,
there'll be like a layer of alcohol on top of it.
Now it's all solving Looch you're like a micro brewer.
Yeah,
exactly.
Oh,
it's literally called who literally is how pure alcohol booze got called hooch.
Yeah.
It's a fermentation.
This is already the most informative podcasts I've ever done.
That's fucking awesome.
So the New York Times did an article on people with their sourdough starters and
just,
you know,
I've been doing it for like a year and they came into my house and took pictures
of me with my starter and I was in the food section.
This is,
I'm not doing anything,
show busy with this.
I'm just baking bread with my daughter having,
isn't that always how it comes about when you,
when you're not trying not at all.
And uh,
my friends back east well for the New York Times and then calling me that day,
like,
what are you doing?
Why are you in the food section?
So it just became a thing and then people started sending me things.
I'm Twitter and Facebook or whatever,
uh,
showing me that there are attempts at baking like,
and that's a massive subculture.
Yeah.
It's not even just people who bake like specifically big bread.
People who are into bourbons like this,
all of these subcultures thing that when you all of a sudden get into it.
Totally.
Yeah.
You just be like open the door a little bit.
All of a sudden you see those like,
you know,
a million people and they're like,
yeah,
yeah.
You're like,
wow,
look at all these Instagram accounts of people doing what I'm doing.
Is it just kind of,
uh,
took off and was super fun.
And I also,
at the same time that I started baking it,
I also started getting on this kick of,
uh,
this is why are we the first generation it Brett has been around for thousands
of years.
Why are we the generation that's being told we shouldn't eat bread?
Why all of a sudden are we now like,
no,
you're the new human beings that can't eat bread.
And I was like,
there's something wrong here.
And then when we started baking this bread,
it's just flour,
water,
salt and yeast.
That's all it's in it.
And wouldn't the bread I would buy,
my daughter's in the supermarket trying to get them good bread,
had 30 ingredients in it,
right?
Chemicals,
sugars,
glucose,
all this other isis.
Yeah.
I said it was all in there.
Yeah,
Russian poison.
It was [inaudible].
And I started giving that breadths of my friends that have problems with eating
bread and they had no problems.
We were eating a lot of bread and we weren't getting fat and I was like this is
the pure thing,
this is what bread really is.
So then I started going off on this kick in my acts and it started,
you know,
a permeating other parts of,
it was in my book where I was just like we should be allowed to celebrate in
life.
We should be allowed in.
Can I pitch an episode?
Yes.
An episode.
Cause you got eight already in the can.
Okay.
You're next season.
Tom Teaches bill how to bake bread or even just right.
Even just for the website.
That would be awesome.
I am on this new diet that I've been doing for like the last three weeks and
I've been,
you know,
keeping the muscle and dropping all the fat and I love how I look and everything
but it's just like I,
you know,
am I come,
I've got to have a piece of bread every once in a while.
Every once in a while.
And you eat are what,
okay,
I'll do the shit that I used to.
You know,
you're part of my generation.
I always wonder bread mice,
steak comes on wonder bread and the grease would be going through the brand.
You have to eat it quick before it went through.
Oh yeah.
You know,
how are we going to look up a fork or something?
I um,
and I stand by dude,
I had that today.
I would have to take a nap immediately,
but it would be effing delicious and a child's sense.
Memory Foam,
but your stuff.
Yeah.
Um,
IHR brand.
I was like,
I got to call my parents.
I mean it was just,
it was just like,
it was like a wholesome,
yeah.
Holidays,
everything that like,
you know,
when,
when all the bs slows down in life,
the right it,
you know,
you just got passed something or maybe it's the holidays,
you've got a few days off,
he just have time.
But you actually have free time to hang with the people in your life.
Like this is what it's and so could be.
Right,
exactly.
This is what it could be.
And it's not every day.
I mean these are special moments in your life,
you know?
I mean,
basically the way the show goes is I,
I just pictured you talking to your family.
Like,
don't get Yost today.
It's a special thing.
It,
there's bread in the house all the time now.
Like when I go on the road,
if I'm gone for a while,
they get for the first time they call me.
They're like,
when you coming back and it's not because he wasn't seen.
Do you realize your kids,
they're going to talk about you like some like grandmother from the early 1900
stone.
There was always the smell of bread in our house.
That's right.
I'm out.
I'll always remember her.
I remember her when she passed the casket.
The smells like he's just disgusting.
Sorry,
I should have said bread.
It just took a whole nother angle on there.
So what's your favorite?
Uh,
so basically I go around to all these different cities.
I come into a city and I visit five of the best big goods I can find a bakery.
I'm a sandwich place with amazing roles,
a pizza place,
whatever it is.
Okay,
what paid.
We're dealing with doe and that kind of thing and you quickly realize this back
to it being special,
you quickly realize there doesn't,
there's no need for a bakery in a town.
You know what I mean?
Like there's,
you need the cops,
you need the fire department,
you need the power,
you need the the water,
you'd eat all this stuff.
A bakery is a special little place that's just happens to be in the town that
when you're want to treat yourself or get something nice for your family,
that's when you go to the bakery.
It's this nice little celebration in your everyday life.
You don't go there every day,
you know most of the time.
So all these people are creating this really special stuff and you go in there
and you feel good and that you should be celebrating your life like this is it
like this.
We're not going to,
this is prime time,
right?
This is when we're really going to enjoy ourselves.
You take your daughter and walk into a bakery and give her a cookie.
That is a special moment.
That's a special thing.
You know when she,
when she turned a year and a half last month,
I actually,
I went to a bakery and I bought her a cupcake and put one and a half candles in
it and sang happy one and a half years old.
My God,
she's just looking at me like,
when can I eat the theater?
Nice Song that I dunno what's going on here and get one thing.
Can I have that?
Yeah,
this is special for you.
But I really feel like,
uh,
it's,
it's just,
it's a celebration.
Life should be a celebration.
You don't eat this stuff all the time.
You don't want to,
you know,
you,
you want to be in shape.
You don't want to get diabetes,
but you should enjoy it.
We'll do an episode,
I'll teach you how to make a pie crust.
You teach me how to make bake some bread and that would be great.
We should do it now.
I gotta be honest with you.
Like I,
I just,
uh,
the whole idea of having a comedian who bakes,
you know,
it's weird,
right?
No,
I'm just saying,
I'm like,
what a home run for a show.
Oh,
right.
And then you're going to go check out all these cool bakeries.
Like I dunno,
like,
Hey,
I've had diners drive it and then tides.
It just seems like everybody's always eating like the Burgers,
the Tacos,
the Burritos,
the pizza.
They've had all of those shows.
But I haven't seen a guy big do the bakeries now and like,
you know,
for years.
Yeah.
I've been,
you know,
sort of like a gay bashed in a way that I actually know how to bake and make
pies and stuff.
And I'm like,
why?
It's awesome.
And Women Love Ya.
I remember,
do you know how to bake?
Like they love?
Oh,
completely.
There's a whole,
there was a whole article about a woman that get turned on by and these guys
that bake bread,
remember?
You were so literally,
it's like,
it's like having a saint for me because I'm such an asshole.
It takes down a lot of my shit that I do.
You know what I mean?
If like,
you know what's the edge off?
Yeah.
Like make a scene at the supermarket.
He yells,
he's cutting people off,
but he makes a hell of a pie.
Even your voice changed and makes a hell of a fun,
take some of the edge off you.
Uh,
you brought up high.
Was it last Christmas?
Was it around the holidays?
I can't remember.
Brought me a pie and the center wasn't cooked.
And you also,
you were so bummed out.
I'm going to tell you why.
Because we were renting a house.
Can I get my shit hole one fixed up.
And what happened was the door was slightly ajar and let the heat out.
No,
I made you,
I'm still remember,
send me a picture of it.
I made you.
Yeah,
cause I felt so bad.
I made you a uh,
pumpkin bread for Halloween.
That's where I made,
and it's the easiest fucking thing.
It's just a concoction.
You pour it in the thing,
you throw it the oven and you're done and you leave it.
Yeah.
And it w it wasn't done.
So I had to tell you to put it back in and you were able to fix it though.
But I was,
I was so embarrassed.
And then the fact that you're like this,
you know me is such a good baker.
You're it,
you're in the food section of the Times.
I get a couple of hits on Facebook when I make a pie,
but,
but you know what,
I remember that distinctly.
Like we just ate around the raw part and it was delicious.
That's the cool thing.
Like you don't realize you messed this stuff up.
I still screw up reds cause it takes,
it's a three day process and if you mess up along the way,
you're going to get a flat frisbee.
But I'm telling you the flat Frisbee is delay.
Oh,
still is.
Yeah.
Just push.
It doesn't look good.
Just put some butter on it.
You just,
Oh yeah.
God.
What have you been up to as far as,
uh,
you,
you've been traveling the road,
promoting the show.
You've been doing some dates,
what he'd been up to had a,
uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's not really slowed down.
I have.
Um,
I had five jobs from April until just recently where I was doing my standup of
course.
And then I had a book come out,
so I had to tour around with the book.
I took over the writing for live from here,
which was prairie home companion,
Gerritsen retired.
And um,
Christy Lee took over as the host and uh,
I took over the comedy of it and the writing of it.
And uh,
I also do a monologue each week on it.
And then,
um,
and then I had my podcasts might come to pop up podcast and radio show for
Sirius and uh,
and then baked.
And then when they,
when the red show came,
you know,
as happens in production,
they are like,
yeah,
we might make it,
we might make it.
And they're like,
we want eight in a month.
So on top of touring with the radio show and with my standup and the book tour,
the bread show got thrown on top of it.
So the bread show,
you probably think I'm insane.
Can't going to go.
It's a fun little thing that I'll do.
It's fine.
We'll do a pilot,
throw me a couple of bucks.
This is cool.
We'll do a pilot.
Who knows?
You know,
I wasn't,
I,
the beautiful part of this is I have no show Biz anxiety about this.
I still don't,
I still don't.
I everything else,
you know,
you make stuff,
you sell it,
you try and get it on the air.
You push.
Yeah.
But I also think if you tore her comic and you have your own podcast,
you're making enough money that I don't have any showbiz stress where I love
doing my TV show.
Absolutely love doing it.
But like,
I'm not like in the unemployment line,
right.
If it doesn't go,
yeah.
which I hope it goes by the way,
if anybody's listening.
Yeah.
And just treat drone out there.
He's not appreciating her.
Cheryl.
Um,
yeah.
But this show I completely,
I'm like,
look,
we can do a show about it.
That'd be great.
I'd love to share it with more people that,
that's awesome.
If you don't make a show about it,
I'm still gonna go to the bakery in Cleveland when I get there.
You know what I mean?
So how much time did she said did you buy,
did you have to carve out a USP,
a schedule and keep doing it?
I just threw it on top of everything else.
So while I was doing the book tour,
while I was doing the standup,
I was doing all this other stuff.
I was doing episodes of this show,
uh,
that are going to start airing.
And I literally have not been in my home for a full week since April.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It would just,
it just all,
it was like a tsunami.
Everything,
a perfect storm.
It all just hit at the same time.
How do you handle that?
I just go,
I just go and having a family is,
uh,
and uh,
you know,
I want to be with them and literally bill,
my kids are 16 and 13 now and I was like,
I literally before all of this stuff hit the fan.
I literally said to myself,
I'm going to be smarter about how I tour.
These are the only a couple more years here before everybody starts taking off
on their own.
I'm going to be around a little bit more.
Yeah.
And Boom,
as soon as I said it I was gone.
Huh.
And so that's,
that's the industry.
I know you young people in the industry just say out loud.
You know what,
I'm going to move back east.
Just say that now.
The showbiz Unifor universe will let you move back east.
Yeah.
But let you got it.
I'll get you something.
After you've given up your apartment and all that,
did that just happen you,
was that just having a Dean del Rey?
Oh yeah.
Dean del Ray's like,
I'm getting all these seeds by coastal now,
but he's,
so he went to New York,
like I'm going to be out there for a while doing spots a minute.
The seller,
Blah Blah.
Dude.
He gets to use it for like two weeks.
They got Konan Konan he's got to come back.
It's hilarious.
Actually.
He's on Conan tonight with Mark Marin's.
I'm going to try to go over there for,
for the taping.
Yeah.
That'll be fun.
These,
he's such a good guy.
He's got an dean.
Uh,
you know,
I haven't watched him that much,
but over the last,
you know,
several years he just got you just,
some guys just turn the corner.
They just know exactly what they're starting to do.
Like he got so tuned into his voice.
Yeah.
He's just,
he's Dean onstage and offstage.
Yeah.
He's,
he's a killer now.
Now he opens for me.
He gets,
he gets like sustained rounds of applause when he's done through.
I had to go on after him and Todd rex,
you ever go on at the Todd rex?
No.
Fucking monster.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And both,
you know,
taught as this thing.
What did people love him?
Yeah.
Like he's one of these,
these like a big kid.
Kids love them and adults love him and he is like,
he's like a legit headliner.
Wow.
And what bothers guys on before you?
Yeah,
I did.
But what's good is all but then people come out like a,
and they get to see like a full show rather than some,
you know,
some cupcake you put on in front of you that's up there.
Hey,
whether it's been crazy.
Yeah.
Do you have an notice with raindrops?
Some are bigger than others.
I did a show last night and I am,
uh,
in there the other night and I'm a Michigan Northern Michigan and it was as a
performing arts center.
This nice theater,
beautiful place up in like,
I've never been that nice bakery.
Uh,
no opener.
No,
I just walked out and just did it.
It was kind of lonely like hanging out during the day and stuff.
But um,
I have to say it was kind of you have to do more time.
You know,
you're doing more like an hour and a half,
but uh,
I really liked it.
Yeah,
we'll do that.
Yeah.
Well I do like 90 minutes anyway on top of those guys.
But if I have one guy does like 15,
if I have two guys who both to 10.
Okay.
And I'm trying like,
but you ever just walk out,
you ever just go with nobody?
Yes.
Have I done nobody on the road?
I,
I'm only a few times in my career it becomes a different thing.
It is a different thing.
I think it would be weird at a club.
Uh,
yes.
Just because of what the club does.
So much commotion going on and there's so many drinks.
She got to get out.
So much food to get out and all the fuck all that pomp and circumstance has to
happen.
There's a lot going on.
And then when the headliner comes on,
it's like now we have your undivided attention until we drop all the checks.
So there's always commotion going on with the clubs.
But like in a theater,
I think,
um,
if he comes in the evening with rather than yeah.
Show like I saw,
uh,
who did I see,
I saw Billy Connolly,
I saw him in New York about 10 years ago and if I remember,
yeah,
cause he did like two hours.
Yeah,
he did two fucking hours.
It was unbelievable.
And like at that point that's when guys would kind of like,
if you did like an hour,
I was like,
wow.
Yeah.
Do you mean when headlining was 45 minutes?
Everybody did?
45 45 that's,
yeah.
Insane.
Fucking joke.
In same.
I feel like now if I don't do like an hour and 20 I'm ripping them off.
You know,
and I know.
Yeah.
It's what weird thing,
you know what's weird about it too is that it's kind of like when you do
pushups,
like if you say you're going to do 20 pushups,
18 1920 are really hard.
If you tell yourself you're doing 25 all of a sudden 2124 25 or art like,
it's all about that.
80 to 90 to 125 is going to see like a fucking zillion miles away,
but I know what you mean.
You're shooting.
Yeah,
it just your head,
your head does something.
You say,
I'm going to go do an hour and a half tonight.
That's just the way it is.
If you say you're doing an hour,
all of a sudden you're panting to get to an hour.
All right.
Hey,
you want to answer some questions here?
If you want to help me out,
I give people advice on this.
This podcast.
Yeah,
of course.
You know,
if any of this is going to ruin your bread shelf,
they just let me know.
I'll,
I'll give you.
So last week I,
uh,
somebody mentioned that,
you know,
I actually,
my dumb ass,
I went on,
like,
I was like,
let's see what's going on in the world,
you know,
and,
um,
I don't even know if I want to drag you into this,
but like Trump said that said that killing white farmers in a,
in South Africa,
which has been happening for while.
And I never condoned it.
I didn't say it wasn't a big deal.
I would just,
I was talking about what he pays attention to,
which,
you know,
I don't think if they were Puerto Rican farmers,
he would give a fuck.
And I am,
call me a reverse racist,
but I am basing that on the fact that when there was regular people and then neo
Nazis involves,
he was sitting there going like,
well,
you know,
you can kind of see both sides of the story.
Yeah.
So anyways,
uh,
so this guy wrote,
he wrote in from Cape Town.
So we got a bunch of people from Europe saying,
no,
but blood,
blood,
blood.
You know,
they're just like make then they're not there.
Right.
So we didn't listen to them.
All right,
so this guy,
some Kate time right there.
Uh,
how's it going,
Billy?
Uh,
I'm from,
I'm from Cape Town Africa.
I'm a big
fan.
I listen to your podcasts every week.
Yada,
Yada.
Care for a visit.
I'd love to,
I'd love to go there.
I'd go there.
I have two topics I want to put out there.
First,
my country got some airtime in the news last week due to a tweet by the Donald
Guy.
Now just to recap,
I don't know what this guy's tone is,
but I've read some of the other ones that are all like,
why don't you fucking read a bad,
but they hamper your mouth.
All right.
Now just to recap,
he basically mentioned investigating far murders in land expropriation without
payment and South Africa based on race.
Why are we getting involved in this?
Yeah,
I know.
Why are we getting an invite anyways?
Yeah,
I bet one of the farmers was going to sell him land to build a golf course.
We have to stop it.
All right.
News outlets like BBC,
CNN,
etc. Were quick to point out that these claims were baseless.
And then if you look at the crime statute,
actually see it decline in the farm based attacks though.
I don't look,
I don't watch he got into it because a Tucker Carlson did a thing on it.
Oh I,
you know what I should cause I don't watch the news because all it does is give
me angry.
It's just,
it's a half hour of anxiety with no solution.
Yeah.
And then all this shit that I wasn't worried about,
I now have to add to the shit I already was worried about.
So why would I do it to myself?
Yeah.
And you're powerless to do anything.
All right.
Just to set the record state,
I can tell you that if you search deeper and speak the to the average South
African,
they would tell you a different story.
Being a farmer,
a farm worker is by far the most dangerous job you can have around here due to
the number of attacks and the cold blooded blooded barbaric nature of these
attacks.
Uh,
there is no doubt that the number of attacks has grown in number and in,
in brutality in recent years.
Yet these attacks are not widely reported in the accuracy.
The statistics on the farmers have been appointed dispute ever since the end of
apartheid.
Anyone you talk to?
Uh,
yeah.
The whole fucking thing is there was brutal attacks to get the land and then a
brutal form of government and now there's a brutal reaction to it is my limited
understanding to it.
And I'm not saying any of that was right.
I was just saying it's interesting what old the orange headed lunatic decides to
pay attention to.
Right,
exactly.
That's all I'm saying.
I mean this is,
and I've even said the last election was 2:00 AM at a bar.
Right?
You had to go home with somebody.
You didn't want to leave with either one,
but you had to leave with somebody.
So I am not,
I am not picking a side politically Irena Shit.
Anyways,
anyone you talked to can tell,
tell you have multiple,
multiple of their close friends or relatives who have been attack,
uh,
but effective by an attack regardless of rate brace.
Yet this is not helped by the fact that many political rallies or met with
chance of kill the Bora,
the farmer killed a farmer.
These political parties are basically garnering support on the false promise of
land and wealth to everyone.
Yay.
Communism.
What do you mean gay communism that happened in our country,
man,
we got to rebel against these English guys and then all the rich fucks once we
kicked him out and moved into the rich guys houses.
Right.
And continues to taxes.
This is,
I love when they blamed forms of government.
Yeah.
Is there a form of government that works?
I don't think there is because every,
because you get
at the end you have human beings with unchecked power on some level at the top
and it just,
that's right.
That's all we are.
Some people taste the good life and they don't want to give it back.
No,
no.
That's what's going on in Nicaragua right now.
What's going on about someone else's problems?
It's basically the students are rioting and trying to take the government back
and the guy who they're trying to take the government back took the government
for the people when he was a student,
but then he got fat and happy and now he is like the dictator who doesn't want
to let it go whenever you need,
whenever you taste the good life,
nobody wants to let it go.
Yeah.
You get the extra food,
you get the best booze.
I mean the best women.
Oh my God.
All of that and it's just like my silk robe.
Yeah.
People are cooking your meals.
He's sitting in a hot tub.
Yeah.
You're going to get out of that thing to go help somebody less fortunate than
you.
No.
That's not how people are wired.
They put up gates around their home and they say,
I'm going to keep this.
This is,
I'll read.
I'll read more about this stuff.
I,
I'll,
I'll definitely look up,
but you know why?
But,
but back to your thing about the orange guy pointing this out and bringing us
into like,
I understand that's a big problem when you read about it.
It's like,
Ooh boy,
this is a mass.
Don't we have her own messages?
Like the aren't,
aren't,
aren't like why do I have to jump into this one?
I mean,
there's stuff like that.
No human being to human being yet you're supposed to care.
You do care.
But I can't,
how much time,
you know you could care about everything we get through the Nicaragua thing is a
huge thing.
I mean,
it's,
I don't even know it's gone there.
All I know is this country is fucking bankrupt.
And because we're fighting a war that has no set ending and you're not allowed
to ask about it.
And I don't want to bring this shit up when you got a fucking show coming out.
Um,
it's,
it's just one of those things where it's just like,
I don't understand why,
if I ask like,
hey,
how are we going to pay for this?
Hey,
when are we coming back?
All of a sudden I don't support the troops.
I'm not American.
And I just became like,
I just got my,
I'm,
I'm part of Isis now.
Yeah,
I can do that with us talking about it.
I love the Patriots.
I can sit there and be like,
what the fuck are we doing?
Why did we draft that guy?
People just go,
don't go like you're not a patriot fed you like the jets.
You're a piece of shit.
So it's a very weird,
it's a weird time that you can't because there's a bunch of people afraid to say
stuff that we,
everybody kind of agrees with.
Yeah,
but don't you think also that there's a lot of real like reasonable people that
are thinking the same thing you are on whatever issue,
thinking the same thing and when you do bring it up,
they agree and quietly go about their day.
Like normal people,
they come up after the show after they didn't laugh and say,
yeah,
I,
you're 100% right on the blah,
blah,
blah.
I totally agree with this.
Or I had a dad just like that.
What are the fuck that you were talking about that made the crowd go quiet?
I,
you know what it really is.
I can't believe how many people are afraid to get in trouble.
Yeah.
Like basically get yelled at on Twitter.
Right.
By who?
By who is the loudest,
loudest one.
Right.
It's just,
that's what I'm saying.
There's so many more people that aren't tweeting hateful stuff at you.
I think most of it has to do with a corporation.
God forbid if one extra nickel that they could have made rolled out the fucking
door,
that's the only time they do the customer is always right,
is with that shit.
Right.
Everything else you can go fuck yourself.
You can go to the website and stare at the screen and try and figure it out
yourself and maybe you'll get a portion of a refund or something.
I don't want to get all gloom and doom here with this stuff.
So let's,
let's talk sports,
man.
Um,
I was really watching the red sox and uh,
then I just a duty,
I have to tell you what,
like this is the regular season man.
I know,
but it has been such a crew.
I'm a Yankee Fan.
Right.
And it has been set by the way.
Congratulations.
It's been,
must've been a fun ride your whole life.
It wasn't when I was a kid.
Well I had a little Greg nettles,
Reggie Jackson when I was really little and then I had to go the whole eighties
without as world series.
Do you realize if you guys don't win it this year or next year,
that is the only second time.
You haven't won a world series during a a decade.
Yeah.
Do you the level of success that that is fucking ridiculous.
Not to mention I think two decades.
You want at least half of them in the forties and 50s while yeah.
But I mean I can't,
I know,
who knows what was going on back then.
There was a Bobby socks and Frank Sinatra one during my time.
Right.
We went through horrible periods when they were like trying to buy people and we
never in and it was always messed up.
But the Jeter years,
homegrown kids.
Great cause you guy got the,
I got kicked out of baseball and he would have got rid of half of them.
I don't think Jeter and I don't think he would have known what you would agree
on a Rivera was going to be because nobody did.
Cause you guys had him pitch in like no,
but it'll relief.
Oh Neil would have been gone.
Bernie Williams would have been gone.
Well O'neil you got from the reds eat.
They wouldn't,
they would not have hung on to these people.
He was but it was homegrown.
It was,
it was pure.
I have a guilt.
I have guilt as a Yankee fan when you buy and you know you've got Johnny Damon
and all of a sudden the,
and even the outfield.
I don't like that money part of it.
Oh we we we are going to write over the cliff with yeah.
No like I,
well they're in our division.
This is how you play.
So now you guys are doing it the right way.
We're doing it the right way and it's been a great season.
I love baseball,
right.
My favorite sport and I'm enjoying the hell out of us.
Young guys scraping,
enjoying it.
The second best record in all of baseball and we can get close to the red sox,
but this is what's great though.
What is so great is the greed of baseball.
We're now,
they have to have 9 million rounds.
Like back in the day,
if we slept swept you in August.
Yeah,
that would have been a big thing.
But back in the day I was would have been as a red sox fan.
Okay.
How'd they going to fuck it up this time?
Cause they always did.
But that would immense something.
Yes.
That didn't really mean anything because,
because all our doesn't mean anything.
Yeah,
because you guys are going to get the wildcard.
We'll get one game,
play off against a Oakland or something and we'll lose and be out in one game.
So first all,
why didn't,
you know,
I don't like the one.
What's the one game thing?
Well you have the one game,
the one game playoff.
Oh,
so they added that and then this,
the three game and then the forest and then the four,
right?
Yeah,
but guys doing up there white,
you never,
you never lose.
You never lose.
How many wins did they have?
Uh,
last I checked they were like 91 and 41 or,
yeah,
we just got lucky in 41,
three.
So,
but no,
we were,
uh,
tonight.
I didn't know.
I didn't,
well,
I'm taping this Sunday night too,
so don't confuse you guys as good.
Are you guys as good as uh,
as this record shit?
No,
no.
Nobody ever is.
Your regular season record is never as good as you are because you're,
you're rolling up all these stats on people who aren't going to be there in
October.
Switch.
You have to do is you've got to look at like we just played,
we just played,
uh,
the Indians who I think Terry Francona is still the best managers in baseball.
Everybody sleeping on them.
Nobody gets more out of their place in this fucking guy.
And we played a four game series.
We split it the first two games he made us look like a 500 ball club and then
our big free agent guys,
you know,
sale and price came in and shut up down.
Right.
Okay.
Now here's the thing,
you fucking like Houston,
they got for Atlanta,
they got all those get dented offending world series champion.
Nobody's talking about it.
They're so good.
Exactly.
And they probably had a couple of injuries and whatever,
blah,
blah.
All I know is come October,
we're all zero and zero.
I think clearly there might pick to,
to take it again.
And what ESPN does about regulus seasons is what the news does about like Isis
where in my head,
isis was powerful enough to come over here,
attack this country and overthrow it.
Right.
Until I actually sat down,
I was like,
they don't have a plane or a boat or uniforms.
Right?
This is not Germany and Japan again.
Okay.
So,
uh,
there's fucking,
um,
they do the same thing with,
they basically said the race was over when we swept you guys four games in a
fucking rock knowing do we have like 12 games left?
Yeah.
Injuries happening to try and get to the one on the 18th or 19th.
So I've,
dude,
I've done this too many times,
is a sports fan to know to try to put my seat up in August.
I know.
Say anything's over.
I watched his flow a 12 game lead.
Like I dunno how many years ago,
four or five years ago.
I watched this blow,
that classic 18 game lead and 78.
Yeah,
I've,
I've seen the Tok role.
I've seen the,
the fucking,
uh,
I've seen it all through this fat and roughing the passer.
There's still that insecure.
I've been beaten by my,
I've seen of Dalles roll through guys legs and so great.
I was at dinner with my brother in law and his wife the other night and a red
sox fans.
And there's literally,
when we were talking,
we were still nine and a half up.
But yeah,
it was the Cleveland.
And they lost the first game in Cleveland and the Yankees won that night and we
got a half game up and I was like,
here it comes.
Here comes the slide.
This is the beginning of it again.
And I was just talking out of my ass because they're so solid.
But the fear in my brother-in-law's eyes like,
oh man,
it really is.
This is the beginning of,
because he's gone through it like passing.
You get millennials.
They'd be like,
yeah,
fuck you.
We got this Yankee stuck.
They don't even,
they don't know.
No,
they don't.
Oh No.
I went to Fenway for the first time this year in the beginning of the season.
Horrible,
rainy night.
But,
uh,
that was my first time there.
I've watched so many games at Fenway on TV.
It was so surreal.
I felt like I had been there before.
Oh yeah.
When you're sitting in the thing,
like when you're walking through and trying to get food.
And so when I go back now,
it's not the ballpark I went to as a kid.
I mean they got like a mall in the right field and got people sitting up on the
green monster.
It is so different for when,
when I left the Green Moss would,
it didn't have any advertising,
anything.
I think it looks way better with the advertising and,
and early in Ted Williams days or pre Ted Williams,
dom dimaggio days,
it's something I believe they had advertising there.
So it's gone through like a bunch of stuff.
But uh,
dude,
I was just thinking all this shit that I've seen,
I've seen the Celtics,
any game seven with the Lakers had seen the refs call 30 something files on them
and like 15 on the Lakers in a game.
Seven.
I literally watched the Lakers beat us from the foul line and they ate.
These weren't,
we wasn't,
we were out there hacking people who so fucking anticlimactic.
Um,
Rudel I've seen too many men on the ice.
I,
I've,
I've too many.
Like,
I don't give a fuck how many games were up until,
but they also had this taken out of your ball and you'll have the little snow
plow to give a thing for the guy shakes.
Every team has had those things.
All,
all of that shit.
Yeah,
that too.
I have to tell you that deflate gate
is up there with any like as far as like the music man,
you could redo the music man with the flaky if they like the study literally
found that like the cults also had like three balls that were slightly
underinflated ESPN did a study or it's of course that showed that the ball
actually got there a little bit later.
So it'd be an advantage.
Does affect defense.
So of course they pulled that immediately and a bunch of pats fans had recorded
it going like what?
They don't want you to know.
Right.
So why?
So why Wa looking back now I feel like what was it they don't do?
They did something they fucking,
cause we were in with with good Dell and then something happened and then we
would just fucking out.
I think part of it was,
well I think part of it was when they under suspended ray rice.
Uh,
and they would just like,
yeah,
a couple of games and then they tried to say that they didn't see it.
Then you found out they sought and then Goodell,
he's making like 35,
$36 million a year.
Um,
then I think he,
he,
he just started over suspending everybody.
And do you think it's like if we go after the golden boy that'll kind of take
the heat off of the whole league?
No.
What I think what ended up happening,
I think we,
the combination was that,
and then we had some sort of falling out with the guy and then we took them to
court and in a court of law,
I mean it got laughed out of court that judge actually yelled at the NFL for
wasting their time.
Really?
So a lot of people forget that.
So then he played the next year and not suspended.
So then what,
you know,
now,
he can't have double jeopardy.
You can't get tried for the same thing.
So the NFL went back and changed their argument and said,
and said,
is the NFL a corporation?
And they said yes.
And they says,
does a corporation have a right to suspend an employee?
And they,
and they,
if they feel fit.
And they said yes.
And they said,
well,
Tom Brady is an employee of our corporation and he is,
he is suspended.
And they couldn't mess with that.
So that's what we got.
That's he just,
so he sat down for four games because if Tom Brady and the Patriots took the NFL
to court and won and reversed it,
that was going to open the flood gates every time helmet to helmet head and
suspension,
all this could potentially,
you know,
a corporation thinks like,
oh my God,
the amount of money in legal costs,
we'll have the nuts running them,
the not house they had to fucking suspend them.
Right.
So that is my totally biased patriots.
Yeah.
You know,
as far as like I'll be taking air out of the ball.
We tried to steal signs.
Yes.
As is everybody else.
Which is why when you watch a college football game,
my favorite thing ever,
when you watched them,
when they send into signals,
there's like four guys doing it right.
If somebody is holding up a picture of Urkel that guys,
you know,
fucking pop lockin you know,
and I also love to like that whole idea that if you film somebody,
you know what they're doing,
like they're miming throwing the ball or handing it off or punting it.
You still have to figure it out.
And,
and as much as we weren't guilty with the,
uh,
of,
of the spy gate thing,
I mean,
if you're going to sit there and say,
oh yeah,
first of all,
everyone else's pure,
well the thing about that is,
is that was the first game that that was illegal to do that.
What do you mean that was enough?
Well,
that that was legal.
You are allowed to,
Jimmy Johnson even said,
he goes,
I came in the league,
they say,
okay,
what do I do?
He,
you get a camera pointed at their guy looking at it at halftime,
whatever you can steal,
steal.
Oh really?
So I think it just looked bad after a while.
So the rule was to just that you couldn't have a guy on the field,
you could still have a guy up in the booth that is something called a Zoom Lens.
Right.
It's still doing it.
Everybody is still fucking doing it.
So it's funny.
Yeah.
So if you're going to spend any money,
you're going to say steal and science,
then we should have to forfeit world war two.
Do you have a college team that you like or you're like,
yes,
yes.
I have a bunch of that I like,
but Lsu is my adopted one.
That's your adopted,
I just loved the a sec.
Uh,
this was 10 years ago,
about 2008.
I was after a Nick Saban was there and I was into a less miles and you know,
he would keep it to stew,
that ship,
you know,
it was almost like he was,
his offensive mind was where the people in the upper deck was where they like go
far
and he would just do it.
Yeah.
And it worked for a little while.
The LSU,
they're big.
They're big thing is they've never,
they,
and since I've been watching them,
they haven't had a quarterback that they've believed in enough to let him play
the full game.
And they are literally playing a lot of times the stereotypical like old school
stereotypical white quarterback,
a black quarterback thing where it's like it's a passing down.
You'll get the white guy in there.
Right.
So running the,
we could maybe run the option here,
get the black guy in there and it's just like,
that's hilarious.
Hit One and just go and let them get into the,
the,
the feel of the game as it'd be like,
Hey Tom,
I never liked hosting.
Yeah.
Cause it's like you get them going,
you get him going and then you've got to bring somebody up at such an art and
then you sit down,
you fucking,
you know,
thinking about your day the next day and it's like,
oh fuck,
I got to run back up and do another five minutes.
Yeah.
Um,
my favorite thing and hosting was we're going to,
yeah,
we're going to keep the show moving right along and bring the next guy up.
I always,
my favorite thing with hosting,
I'm not going to do anytime it was between are we going to keep this so much
just murders or it's going to keep the show going.
I kind of,
I really like how the comedy store doesn't have a host.
I really like,
yeah.
How did they just bring everybody up?
You just bring each other on?
I didn't,
I didn't think I was going to like that.
It's,
it's pretty awesome.
Oh,
you want to talk about a place that just turned around?
I don't know if you ever,
I was living out here in the late nineties and when you went down to the comedy
store,
I mean also no one knew who I was.
I was struggling to get spots,
but that place,
first of all there was nobody there.
Now it's spooky.
Yeah.
And it was like,
oh to the vibe hype.
Like it was like,
it was like a fucking haunted house.
Like you went in there and there was all of these guys,
these guys that were on TV and they were big names and they would come in and
just burn the light.
They would just stand there.
Yeah,
having not done the work now,
didn't write anything new.
We're just standing there leaning against the Mike saying,
yeah,
so what else is going on?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
And you're sitting back there,
you know your spots pushed back.
Five minutes,
10 minutes,
40 minutes,
an hour and a half,
two hours.
I'm going home.
I can't go home if I go home.
They don't know me.
So I,
I,
you just have to,
would have to fucking stay there.
Gruden and um,
and all these young kids were learning Sunday when I get on his show,
I'm going to do that.
All right.
And I,
and I remember
being here in 98,
and it was right as Seinfeld was wrapping up in Jerry the first time ever.
All these years I'd been out there and he popped in at the Improv and I was
like,
Holy Shit.
Right.
It's the king.
And he went on stage,
was supposed to do 15 minutes.
He did 15 minutes,
right.
He started with the killer Joe.
He ended with a great job.
Even better joke in the middle.
He tried out as new stuff and I just,
I just clicked.
I was like,
that's the way you do it.
That's a fucking pro.
And that other shit is just ego and oh,
that's all it is.
I got to show,
oh yeah,
yeah,
no,
that place was spooked.
I remember going there,
the store back then and it was like,
this is not going to help me.
I'm like,
this is going to make me depressed.
It was,
it was,
it was fucking hostile.
It was really was.
It was hostile.
And I remember,
uh,
there was a couple rays of light over there.
Rogan.
I remember meeting Rogan for the first time at the laugh factory and I wrote
over yet,
of course he had this fucking bad ass,
cool car currying words that I,
that's really what I remember about those days was just watching Joe come in and
really cool car.
I'm like,
wow,
that guy's really got it going on.
Yeah,
he did.
Yeah.
Some sick ass tail fin.
There was some sort of Japanese sports car,
I can't remember.
So some turbo powered something and we went over there and this and he basically
gave me like a pep talk.
Oh yeah.
On the mindset you hit it wasn't,
wasn't specifically pointed at the comedy store.
It was just the La comedy scene.
Right,
right.
Like how you had to be,
don't fucking listen to anybody,
get in there,
do your job.
And just like,
it was like a real,
like it was like a eight point power Joe Rogan PowerPoint thing that's great on
the mindset and that looked like,
and he was like a,
he was young.
Yeah.
Joe.
So he was like,
yeah.
It was like,
is this guy going to like help me a fucking rip my head off?
Like,
he was like the most amped up dude I'd ever fucking been around.
Uh,
and uh,
fortunately he turned out to be like just a sweetheart of a guy.
Yeah.
And really the kind of the heart of what turned that place around.
Like,
I'll do him calling out fucking medicine and all that.
dude,
I was like,
it was,
it was fucking ridiculous.
I was like coming in there with a big can of raid,
just spraying it on cross the whole comedy store.
It was unbelievable because like the,
the terror that you had yeah.
You believe,
yeah,
he pulled in,
he pulled in the thing and you're like,
fuck,
I'm going on next.
Right.
And all the work you wanted to do,
you could not do.
You put,
not fucking do,
I mean I want to start that shit up again,
but like it's amazing now.
I mean when you walk in there now it just,
just the original room just to go and have a place to really work.
Like you really are going to get work done.
Yeah.
And what's funny is looking at rogue and look how big Rogan is and what does he
do?
He does it like Seinfeld you 15 he goes up,
he does 15 tries out the shit he wants to try out.
He kills,
you know,
so work on your stuff and go.
But it's amazing though,
that usually wants a place or a scene goes bad like that.
It's very rare that it comes.
Yeah.
It's like a movie in a movie that happens.
I know,
but Juno's triumphs over evil.
Yeah.
But similar to what you were saying about seller being like that special room
and something just happens there.
Places have something to them.
Yep.
The laugh factory is always going to be the laugh factory.
The sellers always going to be the seller.
You know what I mean?
Like you,
it was unreal,
man.
You may dip and have bad times,
but that room is begging to be good again.
Yeah.
You know the one that I remember way back in the day,
uh,
in the 90s when we were coming up,
if you on the nine o'clock show Saturday night at the comic Strip,
Oh my God,
I made,
it was so,
it was like you'd come off and think you the greatest comedian of all time.
Yes.
I'm ready to do Letterman.
That room energy of that square room,
that centered stage.
Yeah.
It was unreal.
Yup.
On that one and that route.
And that's a club that's,
that's gone in the toilet and it's just waiting to come back.
You put the right person booking it and start attracting the good guys back
again.
Cause that room,
the architecture,
the energy,
when human beings are in it,
it's waiting to be great.
I was still in New York,
I would still go there even if it's going through a bad period.
It's just like just to keep it going.
Yeah.
Then you got to use,
we use whatever juice you have to keep cause how does that help comics?
If there's one less room,
forget about a room like that.
What you do that,
that room was fucking crazy,
crazy,
crazy.
Do you remember when,
uh,
what would the,
where the names,
the team red Johnny and the round guy.
Oh God.
When they would go up at the comic strip,
I mean to follow him at the fucking Boston Comedy Club.
Nothing was bigger.
Nothing was bigger that they would just rip the roof off that place.
I mean to don't like when they,
when they used to be down to the fucking Boston to comedy club and they,
and they would do the fucking [inaudible].
It takes two,
it takes two to make it
and one of them is gone.
And then remember Matt Frost,
who's down ca,
he would be flicking the lights bucking on and off like it was a nightclub and
the place would be going nuts.
They was some,
it was some joke that they did about going to a dance club and feeling like an
asshole.
And they just like,
when they went into that bit,
it was like you were at a fuck.
It's like you started watching a movie.
Yeah.
And you'd be shocked.
I remember just standing there going like,
I have nothing,
nothing,
nothing in my arsenal in my whole career.
Never.
You could take all of it and slam it together.
I have nothing that could follow that.
And I,
oh my God.
And going up in that fucking room after those guys and bombing,
it was the loneliest fucking thing.
Like,
I mean I,
if I ever saw comics start crying and that I wouldn't even judge them because
that was back to when the club where all the comics sat in the backpack.
But you had to walk to the front of the stage and go up in the middle before
they had that side.
Yes.
And they would just be back there.
And I remember I was,
this kid came down from Boston,
nobody gave a fuck.
I remember running to Todd Barry calling like going like,
ah,
how do I get in it?
Like asking you that fucking question where there is no answer,
how do I get in at the clubs?
He's like,
yeah,
I dunno man.
Just keep doing it.
You know,
just,
you got to hang out and it,
and I know and I now I know what he was thinking like,
hey dude,
I'm trying,
I'm still trying to get it,
you know,
and you'd sit back there and you'd watch like a towel and Kevin,
Brandon,
all these guys that were like already made men.
Like in the end everybody had an edge and there was no like joy of like,
come on along,
I'll show you the way.
It was just mean tough guys who got a spot and you weren't taking it from them
and screw you to get the member to stay til two o'clock in the morning and let
me,
I dare you to complain.
Yeah,
I dare you.
And there was a bunch of comics he used to hide uptown because they didn't want
to go downtown.
It gets their feet,
they went down there once it takes two to make it.
Thank you already fuck that.
I am not going below fucking 23rd street and they were scary up there was scary
down there.
It was a,
it was like Armageddon and I used to walk by the Boston during the day when it
had that shit.
Read awning that look turn pink.
It looks like an old peep show bill it fucking front.
I used to,
I used to get sick to my stomach when I would look at it and I,
and I did.
That was the main dread where I was just like,
I have to get over this fucking feeling or I am not going to make it in this
city.
I know cause that is fucking not,
I'm just walking by the building and it's like that bully I have to fight.
Yes.
Completely.
I remember saying to Kevin Brennan,
we were up at the standup New York and uh,
he's like,
was talking just about this and I said yeah,
but you know,
we got to keep going cause it's making a stronger,
right.
We gotta go cause make her stronger.
Everyone goes,
it's comedy.
I mean how fucking strong do we have to be?
Yeah.
I remember this comic to bitch and say that they should,
this should be no heckling.
There should be no heckling.
He's like,
he'd go to a Broadway show,
there's no heckling and I don't want to be like,
well fucking go,
go fucking get a job on Broadway then Duke because I don't think that there
should be any heckling that's like,
I think that's what makes stand up so fucking cool.
Is that,
yeah,
that is actually,
you know,
that's part of it that somebody is going to do that.
Yeah.
There's the energy that something's good that this is going to be different
tonight than it was last night.
And I would maybe because of me,
it might be cause the audience maybe because of the Moon,
who knows?
And the fact that some people heckle is also what keeps a lot of people from
never,
it weeds out a lot of people.
Yeah.
Which is a gun on both sides.
I don't want to keep you here too long.
I know you're,
you're onto a bunch of other podcasts to promote your show.
I stay here all day.
We'll also,
we want to have enough time for good.
Frick cigar maybe.
Who knows?
We'll start one.
Finish it at home.
Yeah,
you could do that.
All right,
let's do that.
Let's do that.
Tom Papa,
the show's called baked.
It comes on September,
September 3rd day night.
10 Day to two episodes.
Starts at 10 o'clock east 10 o'clock hasn't September 3rd,
and it's gonna run every Monday through September.
The first one is,
uh,
the first one actually is New York and,
okay.
My Buddy,
uh,
our buddy Jim Gaffigan stamps buy a doughnut shop while I'm there.
Oh,
that's awesome.
Yeah,
that's great.
All right.
I've already pitched myself for the second season.
I can't do it.
So happy for you success,
buddy.
Thank you buddy.
All right,
sue the best.
Right?
Okay.
Now it's time for the reeds here.
I apologize to all the people that wrote in above the farmers down there and,
uh,
South Africa.
I'm going to read up on that and I will read the rest of that guy's email.
Um,
um,
on Thursday.
Okay.
That's my promise.
Now,
if you know me,
I'm scatterbrained,
so I might forget.
Okay.
But,
uh,
I don't take innocent people dying anywhere lately.
It had nothing to do with that has to do with the other bullshit.
All right,
with that,
let's,
uh,
do some reads here.
Oh,
men mobile.
what do you get gum when you fucking,
she'll have you kissed,
ticked.
Um,
mint mobile.
Uh,
the big in big wireless providers stands for a lot of things,
big contracts,
big bill's big phase,
big pain in the fork in HD.
What big wireless doesn't want you to know is that there's a way to cut your
wireless bill down to just 15 bucks a month.
No Way,
man.
How was that possible?
Introducing meant mobile,
the game changing company that takes everything into what that's taken.
Everything.
Oh,
sorry.
Wrong with big wireless and made it right there.
Crusaders meant mobile makes it so easy to cut your wireless bill down to just
15 bucks a month.
Use Your own phone with any mint mobile plan.
Okay.
These guys aren't like separate but equal.
Then I go and uh,
down the south here in the 1960s and fifties.
Um,
they're user friendly here.
You can use your own phone with any mid mobile plan.
You can keep your old number along with all your existing contacts.
Choose between two,
five,
or 10 gigabyte,
four g LTE plans.
Every plan comes with unlimited talk and text.
Jesus Christ.
I'm going to get this unlimited talk and text.
And if you're not 100% satisfaction satisfied mint mobile has you covered with
their seven day money back guarantee?
Well when does the fucking bill camp comes once a month?
How does that work?
Thanks to mid mobile wireless never has to be expensive again.
And to prove that to prove that meant mobile is going to hook you up.
Going to hook up 10 of my listeners with free wireless for a year.
Holy Shit.
Seriously free wireless for a year.
Enter to win one year of mint mobile service with five gigabytes of data per
month.
Um,
10 potential winners will be drawn from eligible entries received between August
27th and September 10th a and you write me if you win it cause I want to make
sure that they give us all 10 winners will be announced September 15th,
2018 visit mint mobile.com/burr B u r r for your chance to win.
And for the complete official rules meant mobile.com/burr no purchases necessary
and open to legal residents of the 50 United States,
us states and the district of Columbia.
You must be 18 years or older at time of entry.
All right,
now Robin Hood.
Robin Hood is an investing app that lets you buy and sell stocks.
ETF tfs is whatever the fuck those are.
Options and crypto.
Crypto,
Leo's all commission free.
What a cryptos.
What do you invest in in fucking robots in the future?
You creep,
uh,
they strive to make financial services work for everyone,
not just the wealthy pigs,
non non intimidating way for stock market and newcomers to invest for the first
time with true confidence.
Now the stock market is just like gambling in Vegas,
only play with money you can afford to loose.
All right,
simple and intuitive.
Clear design with data,
uh,
presented in an easy to digest way.
Values of the Robinhood APP are as follows.
Cost slash no commission fees.
Other brokerages charge up to $10 for every trade.
But Robin who had doesn't charge commission fees,
fee trade,
uh,
fees,
trade stocks and keeps and keep all of your profits.
Sorry,
I could read that a little more clearly.
Other brokers charge up to 10 bucks for every trade,
but Robin had doesn't charge commission fees,
trade stocks and keep all of your profits.
Everybody.
It's easy to use,
easy to understand and charts and market data,
place a trade and just four taps on your smartphone.
Robinhood web platform also lets you view stock collections.
100 most popular sectors like entertainment,
social media,
and curating categories like female CEOs for a little reverse sexism there,
but you know,
they female CEOs probably need help,
right?
Help out the ladies and invest in their companies.
Provided it's a good company.
You know,
the end of the day you can be part of a cause,
but it's your money there.
And analysts,
analysts,
a ratings of buy slash hold slash sell for every stock.
Learn how to invest and build your portfolio.
Robinhood is giving less listeners a free stock like apple.
Robin Hood is giving listeners a free,
a free stock like apple,
Ford or sprint to help build your portfolio.
That's hilarious.
They're undercutting sprint and let you invest in them.
So they're good guys.
Sign up at Bill Burr,
uh,
Robin hood.com.
That's Bill Burr Dot Robin hood.com I read it wrong the first time.
Bill Bar Dot Robin hood.com all right.
Oh,
look who's back end.
Ge.
Don't talk about how every man looks better in a suit.
I don't know how to do this anymore.
You know what?
Every man looks good in a suit,
no matter how long their tie is dangling between their junk,
the end of the day,
they look better than that.
They're walking around,
you know,
here's the thing.
You want to meet a woman?
Okay,
you got to take respect in the way you dress.
All right,
and I know you want to be that guy.
Dress down Friday all the frigging time,
but I'm telling you,
you put on a little habit dash Sheree.
They're all right.
They,
you take a risk.
Yeah.
You show a little respect for yourself in the ladies will notice.
You know,
I wonder if they make like those power suits than Hillary Clinton war for the
ladies.
I have no idea.
Additional copy points for Indochino is the,
it's the world's largest made to measure men's wear company and has been
featured in major publications including Gq,
Forbes,
and something called Fast Company.
Uh,
they make suits and shirts made to your exact measurements for great fit guys.
Love will love the wide selection of high quality fabrics and the option to
personalize all the details,
including your Lapel lining and Mano Grid.
Okay,
this is like Conor McGregor shit.
For someone like myself who does not have fight,
how great this Conor McGregor look at every way or whatever,
whenever he's sitting there talking shit about everybody killing it better than
most comics.
I know the man always looks well.
Why it was looks great because he is designer suits.
You could do it too.
Here's how it works.
Visited show room or shop online@indochino.com pick your fabric,
choose your customization,
submit your measurements way for your custom suit to arrive in just a few weeks.
And then you've got a custom suit.
So if you show up where everybody else has a suit on,
they just bought it off the rack.
They don't got their initials there,
then I've got that snazzy lining that you're going to have.
Right.
Visit a showroom or shop online@indochino.com uh,
this week my listeners can get any premium Indochina suit for just 379
bucks@indochino.com.
That's probably what,
how much fucking Conor Mcgregor's pocket square costs,
but you're working your way up when entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% 50% off the regular price for a made to measure premium suit plus
shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo code birth for any premium suit,
three and $79.
It's incredible deal for soup that will fit you better than anything off the
rack,
ever will.
All right.
Ah,
but though too beyond ease me on ds,
they killing all the fucking farmers.
Do,
do the Doobie Ids me undies and then they go get some Shwarma that taking the
land back that was stolen from fucking innocent people.
Where is it ends?
Alecia balls will be nice and soft when they come in with the fucking machetes.
Um,
me,
Andy,
sorry.
You've definitely heard me talk about me undies.
I just rhymed.
Farmers were Shwarma.
That's not bad,
Huh?
I showed a little fucking m and m there,
you know he had bends the fucking word.
All right bill.
It didn't rhyme.
Whatever.
I thought it was pretty good on the fly.
You know the fun,
comfy undies that feel as good as they look to.
Those of you haven't tried them yet.
Listen Up.
You get incredible underwear sent to your door with me undies meaning no more
hunting around for the perfect pair at a crowded store and eventually settling
for good enough.
Just picture you walking around in your skivvies drop and trial is a trial,
so is dropping trout for the longest time,
but it's travel like you putting the,
you're taking down your trousers,
which always reminds me of that Louis Ck joke when he was talking about calling
up a phone,
sex line and you know,
he's got that old woman talking dirty to them.
I'm going to take off your trousers.
Um,
some jokes just stick with me.
meaning no more hunting around for the blah,
blah,
blah.
Me undies are made.
What they sustainably sourced material from beechwood trees.
This is our confident these guys are,
they're putting trees in their underwear and somehow it's still more comfortable
than cotton.
This naturally soft fiber makes a fabric that won't sag down or to rip.
Trust me,
I got a pair of these that all of this is true.
Once you put on a pair,
you're going to get it.
Um,
and if you're already part of the me undies fam,
not family fam that trying to meet you,
the trying to reach the millennials on that line when you're part of the me
undies fam,
Yo,
tell your friends about it.
Uh,
through their referral program,
they'll get a discount and you'll get a store credit.
It's a win win.
Still not sure.
What else do I got to tell you?
Well,
the undies has a deal for my listeners.
First Time purchasers get 15% off their first pair of me undies and shipping is
free.
That's 50% off free shipping and a guarantee that you and your me undies,
we'll be very happy together.
Get your ass over to me undies.
Dot.
Come and treat yourself,
uh,
to get 15% off your first pair and free shipping,
100%,
a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr that's me,
undies.com/burn.
All right,
two more.
Hang in there.
Oh,
it's old zip.
Hiring used to be hard.
I don't know who to pick.
Moon.
Multiple job sites.
Stacks of resumes,
a confusing review process.
Jesus Christ.
Where does it end?
But today,
hiring can be easy and you only have to go to one place to get it done.
Zip recruiter.com/burr.
Uh,
when you go to Zip Europe,
uh,
they send you your,
zip recruiter sends your job's to over 100 of the web's leading job boards.
They don't stop there.
Most people would stop there,
but not zip recruiter.
But they are powerful matching technologies.
Ziprecruiter scans thousands of job resumes to find people with the right
experience and invite them to apply for your position.
As applications come in,
zip
analyzes each one and spots,
lights the top candidates.
See you now.
You don't have to fuck around with people who aren't qualified,
so you never miss a great match.
Ziprecruiter is so effective that 80% of employers who post on Ziprecruiter get
a quality candidate through the site within the first day.
Time is money.
Ziprecruiter understands it.
What results like that?
It's no wonder why zip
code is the highest rated hiring site in America right now.
My listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free at the exclusive web address.
ziprecruiter.com/bird that's zip recruiter.com/burr spell out birth.
Okay.
B U r r once again,
that zip
man,
ziprecruiter.com/berg ZipRecruiter is the smartest way to hire.
And lastly,
but certainly not leastly the headliner of all my advertising for the most part,
stamps.com they've been with me since the beginning.
The US Postal Service is an important tool for any business.
stamps.com is easiest way to access all the amazing services of the post office.
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your convenience.
24 seven right?
Your wife went to bed,
your kids are in bed.
You're going to get a jump on your day,
your pour yourself a scotch and yup.
Yeah.
Your printouts of Goddamn postage.
Print postage for any male class right from your own computer.
The exact,
um,
excuse me,
the exact got the hiccups,
the exact amount of postage every time.
Never underpaid or overpaid.
Again,
stamps.com saves you time and money which you can use to grow your business.
Buy and print official US postage.
This is getting redundant for any letter,
any package,
any class,
some mail using your own computer and printer.
They'll send you a digital scale that automatically calculates the exact
postage,
the post office and all their wonderful shit that they do down there is now in
your house stamps.com we'll even help you decide the best class of mail for your
needs.
You can do it in the nude.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter and there are no long term
commitments.
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters,
which I really need to advertise better.
I have autographed posters,
these amazing posters that people have told me I could sell for 40 bucks at a
show.
But you know what,
I'm a man of the people.
All right?
I only sell them for 20 bucks.
Their autograph to write every one of my God damn shows and people keep walking
out and then they texted me after,
hey man,
I wanted to see the poster.
Where is it?
It's out there in the lobby.
I don't know where.
All right,
I'm sidetracked,
but I use stamps.com to send these fuckers out.
Alright.
stamps.com I use stamps.com I just told you why and right now you too can enjoy
stamps.com uh,
the stamps.com service with a special offer that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com enter burr.
Alright.
By the way,
as I mentioned before,
my great Buddy Dean del Ray's doing his first talk show as a standup comedian,
uh,
tonight,
Monday night on Conan O'brien with the great and brilliant Mark Marin is one of
the guests.
Um,
please tune in and uh,
and check it out.
And after that it says they got a ton of males,
tiny emails about,
uh,
from South Africa.
So I have to read these.
I can at least read the rest of this guy.
Um,
his thing here,
I forget where I left off.
Let,
let's just pick this up,
which brings me to my second point.
Now I don't follow all the news on Trump.
Frankly,
I don't care anymore because it's exhausting.
I agree.
I agree too.
Everybody's screaming and yelling,
flipping the fuck out and nobody has a solution.
Uh,
but the message I get from the media is still the same.
They hate him and we'll blow up any small thing just to take them down.
And basically,
you know,
something that is a problem in this country.
Ever since Bill Clinton,
no one has been allowed to be president without being constantly under attack.
And I really think it hurts to position Democrat,
Republican,
or Libertarian,
whatever you,
you got to let the person tried to do the fucking job,
you know.
Anyways,
they hate him and we'll blow up anything that he'd done.
Hey,
basically they are saying Trump has chosen debate,
team Ei,
therefore we will choose opposing team.
Be A,
that is true with CNN and Fox.
They both do it.
Everybody's making a big deal over every bombshell in quotes,
uh,
in the Mueller probe of he must have known and this lawyer knew about that shit
and pleaded guilty.
Really?
Do you want to tell me Hillary Clinton or any other politician would have the
same kind of,
uh,
at that you've wanted to say wouldn't have the same kind of deal?
Yeah.
Hillary would have been getting attack the entire fucking time.
They all played dirty.
I would never have expected it otherwise.
So my point is,
yeah,
but they don't all play dirty.
Bernie Sanders did not play dirty,
which why?
I don't think it's a waste of a vote to even know the guy's not going to win to
a vote for somebody like that,
because you're trying to encourage more people by seeing the amount of votes
that you can get by being a good fucking person.
I people say you wasted your vote anyways.
Um,
so my point is,
Trump actually noticed a problem in South Africa that requires attention,
but we probably won't get the attention we need because the dumb ass media is
too busy writing South Africa hit back at Trump articles.
Uh,
that's true.
They try to take down everything that he's doing.
But the thing about it is,
is he only seems to notice the problems that hit white people.
Okay.
That's the fucking problem.
And,
and,
and as much as our media definitely would have attacked any republican that went
in there,
the,
the left wing media would definitely do that.
I mean,
I think when you look at Neo Nazis and go,
yeah,
well,
I mean,
did you know people were being aggressive on both sides.
You kind of lose a lot of credibility is all I'm saying.
All right.
But I understand also what you're saying.
Okay.
Continuing.
Um,
wow.
You read it all the way up to here.
Thanks.
Go be an inspiration to all the other hairless ginger's out there.
MMM.
All right,
so there's another one from South Africa.
Bill Clinton's balanced budget myth.
All right,
so it wasn't balanced.
Now I have to one,
like where did this come from?
Now is this people on the right?
Yeah.
You don't know where any of this is from.
Okay,
so now I have to,
I'm just supposed to read this and I'm supposed to look at you and assume that
you're a this guy down the middle.
That votes on both sides.
I will,
I will read this.
You guys are making me more informed,
I think.
Or maybe you're swaying me like that guy who wrote in from Russia,
but I don't know if that's the guy from Russia who's hacked into the Twitter
shit.
I don't know where any of this shit's coming from.
A shark theft.
Hey,
bill just wanted to share this ridiculous story about this guy that stole a
fucking sharp from an aquarium in Texas.
He dressed the shark is a baby and put it on a pushchair and just walked out.
His justification was,
he was concerned for the sharks welfare.
Well,
he probably wanted to put it back in the ocean,
but,
uh,
once he takes it out of the water,
I think the shark was like,
hey man,
I don't think that a query was,
was so bad.
Granted,
it's not as big as the ocean,
and I'm no longer to live freely as a living thing on this planet.
But,
uh,
you know,
if the shark went to rescue you and stuck you dressed you was a baby and puts
you in a fucking carriage and then took you under water,
I think you'd be like,
Whoa,
okay.
Oh,
there is still some due process in this country.
The fact that the article says a man man accused of stealing shark,
I mean,
I think the fact that he had it,
you know,
oh,
I thought this was like,
I thought that was part of the gift bag after you went to the aquarium that you
could take one of the fish home.
All right.
Robin Leach,
uh,
Billy Benz,
you're old enough to remember lifestyles of the rich and famous.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
That was great.
That's one of the first,
yeah,
the blue sort of MTV cribs before MTV cribs,
this Guy Robin Leach and they glorified in and it just all like,
and when they're sitting at the pool that is don't sit at the pool.
They eat.
Escargo I love watching him,
uh,
do an impression for the kids who don't know what he sounded like.
I can't do an impression of him.
I haven't seen it long enough and I'm not good at impressions unless the persons
in my life.
Um,
like I can imitate,
I can imitate.
Um,
I'm working on a Dean del Rey that I'm going to get like a,
he always comes back from concert.
Hey Dean,
how was it?
Ah,
it was killer.
He always goes down or if he's talking about some of the,
there's an asshole.
Oh,
that guy.
That guy's a garbage can.
All right.
The first show to really give you a look at how filthy rich some people are,
was the lifestyles of the rich and famous.
I remember seeing an onyx black bathtub and just thinking that all rich people
had black sinks and bathroom fixtures.
All right.
For those of you didn't grow up in the 80s,
if somebody had an all black bathroom,
they were in the cocaine on an entirely different level.
They were going Kleinfeld you remember Kleinfeld mum were the most underrated
Sean Penn character of all fucking time a car in Carlito's way.
You got to check that out where he was going.
When I love when Pochito said that lie lawyer Kleinfeld you wait a lawyer,
you are gangster.
Um,
the first show really gave you a,
okay.
Anyways,
I remember seeing an unexplainable blah,
blah.
Anything stick out from that show?
Do you have any goals?
Did you have any goals when it came to luxury?
Um,
no I didn't.
I just,
I just was thinking like,
wow,
that's amazing.
And,
but I never thought about money.
Okay.
And it never seemed attainable.
Um,
I obviously was saying,
you know,
when I got older that I,
I,
you know,
I wanted the Camaro Berlinetta
I secretly liked the z 28,
but my older brother also liked that.
And I didn't want to say that I liked the same car cause I thought,
you know,
it would get me into a fistfight,
cause that's just,
you know,
it's how it was back then.
There wasn't any cell phone cameras or whatever.
Like he just got an give,
just fought your older brother and then you try it out,
shit on your younger brothers to try it on your older brother.
But he had the psychological advantage and he always beat you.
So I had to like a different Camaro than he did just to keep the peace.
But when I was a kid I wanted to have,
um,
I definitely,
I wanted to have two bulldogs.
I remembered that I was going to name him butch and chopper butch cause I
thought it was a tough name.
And then chopper,
there was a cartoon I used to watch and one of the bull dog's name was chopper.
I can't even remember which,
and I was going to have a Camaro Berlinetta instead of the z 28.
So I wouldn't get the shit kicked out of me.
But by my older brother and uh,
beyond that,
I don't think the dream,
I don't think that dream went any further than that.
I was going to have a Camaro in two bulldogs.
I never thought about a pool or a finding love for becoming a parent.
I was a kid.
Yeah.
So I used to just watch that and um,
I never gave a shit about tennis courts and stuff like that.
I think I,
uh,
I was into sports,
so I think maybe I wanted to have like an incredible wiffle ball field.
Maybe.
I don't remember.
It was a long time ago,
but,
uh,
I definitely liked old houses even back then.
Cause we,
you know,
for most of my childhood,
I grew up in an old one,
which is why to this day I live in an old house.
Um,
and you guys listened to me complain about having to fix it up.
all right.
Lastly,
but not leastly girlfriend owes me 10 grand,
but I want a break.
I want to break up,
break up with their serve.
Because I'll tell you right now,
if you,
if you're with the wrong woman in life,
her only,
Oh and you 10 grand that you know you're never going to get back.
You got off easy.
Fuck that to go out and crush it in life.
Find a great woman that deserves you.
Treat her right and you will,
you will make,
you know,
and just find a job that you would go do for freak and you will make that 10
grand.
You throw a bunch of Zeros after it,
you're gonna make it back.
And even if you don't make back the 10 grand,
if you have love in your life and you love your job,
it's way better than this.
I would without even reading this.
It's,
you're not getting your money back and no one's going to help you because you're
a man and she's a woman and she's just going to say it was the Gif.
Oh.
And she'll cry a little bit and it's going to be over.
Just walk away.
Walk away.
All right.
All right,
dear lunatic off.
That might be my favorite intro ever.
I've been dating my girlfriend for about four years and she only owes you 10
grand.
Dude,
you're getting off easy.
We dated two years in college and now for our first two years in the real world.
I live in work in New York City and you she only Osha 10 grand.
Oh my God.
I'd break up with her and go fucking Max.
Don't Max out your credit card,
but I would definitely go by a couple of rounds.
Uh,
I live in work in New York City and while she works here,
she lives at home since she's from Long Island.
Oh,
I love,
I love long island chicks.
I have a well paying job for being in my mid twenties.
She does not make money but luckily lives at home and saves on rent.
However,
she does have student loans and a car payment.
About a year ago,
her car needed some serious tuneup work after she got in an accident while
driving without insurance and she didn't have the cash to cover repairs and the
repairs of the other cars since the accident was her fault.
Yeah.
You're dating a child here,
sir.
Uh,
this is not an adult.
Her parents really don't have much money,
so she asks me for the money.
I was hesitant because it's 8,500 bucks.
It was essentially all of my signing bonus.
You got an $8,500 signing bonus,
dude,
I,
I don't,
what the fuck kind of job has a signing bonus where you're not playing in a
professional sports league,
Dude,
you're crushing it.
Just walk away.
8,500.
It was essentially my signing bonus,
but I knew she would pay me back at the time and at the time I thought I was
going to marry her.
All right,
so you're a good guy.
Okay.
It's been a little over.
You were practicing for being married by spending your hard earned money on your
wife.
Fucking up the car.
I mean,
that's part of being married.
Uh,
it's been a little over a year since I lent her the money and our relationship
hasn't been great.
Plus she's borrowed another $1,500 to pay some months of her loans and for a
Bachelorette weekend in Vegas,
I'm going to go out on a limb here saying you're not setting this relationship
up correctly.
Uh,
she hasn't had much luck finding the job,
the right job,
constantly bouncing around is taking that built up frustration out on me.
MMM,
okay.
In all fairness to her,
I haven't heard her side of the story here,
but,
uh,
this is,
this is not sounding good.
Plus she hates the commute.
So she's constantly crashing at my apartment and walks around all entitled and
just makes a mess and eats all the food.
It doesn't clean up or cook or contribute since it's not her apartment.
Dude,
you know what I eat?
You should really do.
You don't even need me.
What you needed to do was to write this letter,
walk away for three days and come back and reread it,
and you'd have all,
you know and just pretend you don't know this guy.
What would you be saying to this guy right now?
Eat The 10 grand and get the fuck out of there.
NFL season's coming up,
dude.
Get the fuck in sports package.
Go hit the gym and enjoy your fucking fall.
As it gets a little colder,
you get to see the leaves turn and she's not their fucking eaten all your God
damn cheese.
It's uh,
she seems like she isn't in a good place mentally.
And even though she says other,
even though she says otherwise,
every so often when she makes it outland just purchase.
I do bring up the fact that she has student loans and owes me money,
which leads to a big fight.
Yeah.
People who borrow money and don't pay it back.
Always turn it into a fight.
When you actually say like,
Hey,
are you going to do what you promised to do?
They start acting like assholes.
This is not a good person,
buddy.
She might eventually become one,
but you don't have time to wait.
Okay.
You're in the prime of your life.
You're in your 20s,
you got an $8,500 signing bonus for whatever fucking job you're doing.
I just hope you're not rating the 401ks of people who uh,
are too old to get new jobs.
Um,
okay.
Yeah,
dude,
I would walk away and you live in,
in New York.
Okay.
There's plenty of responsible driven women out there that don't need a fucking
guy and you know,
you can meet somebody that's at your level and that's what you want to do.
Okay.
If you can marry up but you don't go less than eyeball to eyeball and that's not
what this relationship is from what you're telling me.
I haven't heard her side of the story anyways.
I'm truly different from the girl.
I wait,
I'm truly can considering breaking up with her because she's so different from
the girl I fell in love with.
However,
I feel like she for sure we'll never pay me back and we'll drift into an even
darker place if I ended.
What do you think I should do?
Thanks in advance for your advice and go fuck yourself.
Hey,
here's something I learned.
Somebody else's happiness is not your responsibility and you holding her
accountable and actually breaking up with her if she is an adult,
will cause her to take a long look at herself and figure out what she did wrong.
Um,
if Jesus him as immature as you're describing her,
she's going to blame you after you've done all this wonderful stuff for you,
for her.
Okay.
So like this is a no brainer.
Um,
this seems like the tip of the iceberg and uh,
the fact that she's pulling this shit with you and you're not even legally
bound.
Imagine when you're legally bound and she can take half of ivy thing that you
fucking make.
Where is her ego going to be there?
Then?
She's at the part of the way she shipped right now where she's supposed to be
pretending to be the person that she isn't and she's already behaving this way.
So I would say you're just starting to meet who the fuck she really is.
That's the way this is worded.
So I would say,
you know what?
10 grand that is 10,000 bucks to not be married to.
This is one of the great fucking deals you're ever going to get.
God bless you,
sir.
Enjoy the football season or whatever the fuck you're into,
and,
um,
go on to live in a great life and beating somebody deserve.
All right.
That's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
And I'll,
uh,
I'll talk to Ya.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.